other than um since I think it's time
all right so before we get started who
here is a PHP developer just curious to
see who I'm talking to
maybe cool what other languages people
do
C sharp yeah
Java
cool
nice oh yeah it's a good mix crowd okay
so first question well first thing is
who am I why am I up here talking about
PHP well I describe myself as a crusted
on PHP developer I've been doing it for
20 years I've been a senior PHP
developer for what 13 years or something
and I've been doing PHP security for
about seven years so I've been doing
this for a while
PHP is my language of choice the
language I love working with language I
use every day
um and I figured I should defend it
since it's such a great language
um what else have I got on there so I
spent about 18 months cleaning infected
WordPress sites which was actually
really really fascinating
um looking at malware and viruses and
way that people compromise WordPress
sites and what's going on in their
ecosystem so that was quite fun and gave
me a unique insight into what's going on
in the PHP community and specifically
WordPress I learned a lot more about
WordPress than I ever thought I would
doing that job it was lots of fun
um so last year I stopped being a
developer and started doing being a
security consultant and doing pen tests
and security Audits and so I spent the
year ordering laravel sites and you know
funding security vulnerabilities and
hacking into them and then obviously
reporting those to their clients and so
that's given me a good insight into
what's going on in the PHP community in
terms of security rather than just as a
developer but seeing what other people
are doing reading other people's code
and then in October last year I thought
what the hell let's submit a PHP talk to
NDC because I hadn't seen any PHP talks
NDC before and there's always a few
negative PHP jokes so let's defend PHP
submit a talk it was kind of a joke I
submitted it kind of a joke but always
also as a serious topic because I do
feel strongly about it and they accepted
so here I am let's let's defend PHP
so why why am I defending PHP apart from
the fact that I love it so much well
there are three main reasons the first
one is that it's unfairly attacked PHP
is constantly the butt of jokes it's
constantly being attacked constantly
being unfairly attacked with the words
I've got on there so it's constantly
being put down
um and in my view that is unfair I think
it's there are so many reasons why
there's so many arguments that are put
up against PHP that just don't make any
sense they're outdated they're
irrelevant they're based on older
versions of PHP old applications and
they don't really make any sense anymore
but people still come keep coming out
with the same reasons the same arguments
and it just gets old frankly it's just
old to hear the same tired arguments
again and again attacking PHP so I
figured I'd do something about it
and finally a lot of people don't
realize this but PHP modern PHP
Frameworks are actually really really
secure they have a big focus on security
they they put a lot of effort into
building secure defaults and so building
an application in modern PHP now is
actually really easy and really secure
because you've got the Frameworks and
the things in place to give you that
security
so now before we proceed there is the
the running joke on the internet I don't
know if you've heard of it before but is
PHP dead goes around every so often
you'll get some rubbish article
mentioning PHP is a dying language
I don't think so
like it's only 7.8 of the internet's
running PHP it's not dead look at
everything else by comparison single
digits PHP It's Not Dead
now PHP there are two I I categorize two
different parts of PHP you've got Legacy
PHP and modern PHP and Legacy PHP is
kind of where the problems are in the
Securities are
um modern PHP doesn't have any of that
but people are always talking about
Legacy PHP and thinking about Legacy PHP
and it's kind of where the bad
reputation comes from in a sense so
let's look at the history of PHP where
it came from and to where it is now to
get a better understanding of why what
happened and what caused the Divide
between Legacy and modern
so back in 94 right I'm PHP you know
personal homepage tools was created by
Erasmus letoff and I apologize for
butchering the names I'm Australian it's
what we do
um so it was originally called personal
homeage tools um shortened to PHP tools
and it was a private project by Rasmus
and he's created it in 94 because he was
trying to set up I think it was his um
resume on his site and he wanted some
analytics and some basic basic things
like that some stats and such going on
to see who's visiting his site so he put
together what he called PHP tools as a
way to do that to gain that inside
information because there was obviously
nothing else that he could use that did
what he wanted
and then in 95 in June of 95 he released
the source code to open sourced it and
you can see there's the the release
um post he put up there if you're
interested so that was in June 95 where
you open sourced PHP tools version 1.0
and then in September of 95 he would did
a major expansion on the toolkit added
more to it renamed it the forms
interpreter because he obviously didn't
like the name PHP tools not sure forms
interpreter was a better name but anyway
so he did that
um and it included a bunch of things
like form variables and HTML embedded
stuff and all the things you needed to
do forms and everything else hence you
can figure out why he got to that name
so that was September of 95 and then in
October 95 we had a complete rewrite
and we also had a new name there's a
pattern here you might notice so we had
a new name personal home page
construction kit and at the time
whatever personal homepage construction
kit as it was called was an advanced
scripting interface so it was Advanced
for what it did at its time and it was
really good at what it did even you know
before what it was
um so that was basically version one of
PHP or PHP tools or construction kit or
forms interpret whatever you want to
call it version one was that a really
basic simple scripting interface that
you could use for for doing forms and
analytics and stuff like that
and then PHP fi 2.0 came along so it was
a complete makeover the words in all the
articles I found said complete makeover
I'm guessing it was just a complete
rewrite notice the pattern
um it was also renamed we have phpfi now
which has both the names in it
um that had support for databases and
cookies and functions and a whole bunch
of other stuff like that so that came
out in June of 96 or the debate sorry
the beta came out June of 96 and then in
November of 97 you had the final version
and you can see here an example of what
the code used to look like it was all
done through HTML comments
um which is quite a fascinating way to
do it and kind of reminds me of things
like View and react now where you've got
stuff all interspersed in HTML which is
just weird but anyway um we do have the
wonderful dollar sign variables which I
love some people hate but they they were
back there at version two so they're
cool
um and according to a Netcraft survey in
PHP fi 2.0 was on one percent of domains
on the internet which is a significant
amount for this little project this guy
was running to run analytics on his
resume that's kind of cool
um that's kind of that's kind of where
it started that was the the version two
stages so after version two we had
version three so Andy goodsman Goodman's
and Zeb zaretsky again apologize for the
names
um joined Erasmus in 97 and they had a
plan to build a new engine and build a
new way of doing PHP and make it more
extensible and so they did a complete
rewrite and they also renamed it and
this time it's called PHP hypertext
preprocessor and this is the the final
name so PHP stands for PHP hypertext
preprocessor which is a recursive
acronym
um so page V3 was born at this point had
strong strong extensibility features and
support for multiple databases apis Etc
basically the idea was that it supported
heaps of things and if it didn't do what
you wanted you could easily add support
for it into the language as well because
it was so easy to extend
so that was released in June of 98 and
it was already running on over 70 000
domains at that point so that the betas
and the alphas and everything else were
being tested and used by 70 000 domains
already before they launched the final
version that's how popular it was and
how how good at what it did it was
and in September of 98 we have Pantry my
admin which it shocked me to find out
that it started back in the P3 days I
didn't realize it was that early
can be a speech my admin starts then
um and php3 was on 10 of web servers at
its peak at its most used level which is
um pretty impressive again for this
little project so the php3 now when I
was researching php3 I stumbled upon
this
a function in PHP that
it leaks memories
um it leaks a specified amount of memory
so yeah that apparently useful for
debugging
um back in the day
um yeah I'm sure we all know what we
think of that function
um now this handy person here said guess
what with the result of that uploaded to
an HTTP transport blah blah you know
you've got remote code execution file
upload stuff this helpful person
responds and goes ah just throw a grapp
and they just run and grab via cron and
you can see who's doing it so they're
not saying stop it or anything on
control they just want to I just have an
eye on who's doing what with it really
that's your solution
so this helpful person responds wouldn't
be more elegant to just disable it
because PHP had a disabled functions
feature you could just turn off any
feature in PHP that you want them to use
which is really handy for a feature like
League
um and the powerful person down here
goes oh he just wants he's doing that
tracking and not disabling it really
it's a leak function it leaks memory
really we want this
anyway that's php3 and four
um sorry php4
anyone call out for the new rewrite
anyone guess that one was coming because
it came
um Symphony four wasn't completely right
built on the Zen engine this time um
which was a new way to to build PHP and
support more extensibility customization
all those big fancy words as you can see
from the release announcement here there
was just so much in the language that
there was no point trying to explain all
of it they just
generic statement of lots of improvement
ta
so that was page before it was released
in May of 2000
um pair started in March of 2000 pair is
Petrie's first package manager we'll get
to it later
um we also had the I don't know what
would you call it the Unholy Trinity of
PHP applications Drupal Moodle and
WordPress all started around this time
as well
and so they all started in the WordPress
the the php4 error and they're all still
hanging on today I'm sure we all have
thoughts about them we will get to some
of them later as well so that was page
before when that came out
so after page before we had php5 and
that's just up the drama a bit and I'll
make each thing reveal as I click the
buttons so I got five was released in
July 04 5.1 November 05 5.2 November 06.
everything seems to be tracking on
pretty nicely here and incidentally php5
was the most popular version until
um 2013 which is which is a really long
time
um you've got to guess what happens at
this point things slow down
so these versions of PHP has come out
and then we've got PHP 5.3 in June of
2009. so there's a big gap in there and
we'll get to that in a sec but php3 also
included namespaces and a bunch of other
drastic changes it really should have
been a major version like PHP 6 or
something
um but it wasn't um that's one of the
reasons why so many people stayed on
php5 5.2 I should say
so around this era you also had a bunch
of Frameworks being created you've got
Symphony code igniters and framework Etc
and these are all starting I guess
starting the move towards modern PHP and
modern Frameworks and applications in
PHP rather than using the old Lego
Systems like WordPress and such
in 2009 we had the PHP fig which is the
framework interoperability group and
that's really where Modern PHP started
because the group started and they
developed psr0 which is the standard
requirement recommendation yeah
Peachtree standard recommendation and
that was the order loading standard and
I'll explain what that is in this tag
we're just jumping through quickly
through history here now a round of the
time of all of these versions
we had php6 was started and there's even
a book you could buy a book I think you
could possibly still buy it today you
can buy a book on P36
um anyway so it started in August 2005.
um before Petrie 5.1 and the idea was to
add Unicode spot to the language so yeah
because the PHP was terrible at Unicode
at that point so they wanted to add new
in code support based on optimizations
and changes basically improve the
language
it was abandoned in March of 2010. it
took him so long to make it work it just
didn't work eventually they just gave up
and threw it away they just could not
make pitch V6 work and this is one of
the reasons why 5.3 is 5.3 instead of
six because it came out around here
somewhere when six was still planned to
be six and changing the numbers would
have been hell so anyway they abandoned
php6 and php6 has never been released
it's not a valid version number
um but you can still buy a book I should
really get one that'd be cool I should
have brought it as a prop that would be
great anyway so that was php6 which we
don't talk about much
um after php6 was killed we went on to
PHP 5.4
that was March 2012. 5.5 5.6 comment
then and we can see we're back to a
decent Cadence in years we've no longer
got the large multi-year stretches
between the virgins we now have you know
12 13 14. and in this time in 2011 we
get laravel framework coming out in the
guzzle package um two of very
significant things laravel we'll get to
in a sec
um and in August of 2011 composer gets
released um I'll get to that shortly as
well but that's huge milestone as well
it's kind of Big Technical point to
which modern PHP became a thing after
the PHP fig the standards came out
um April of 2012 we have this thing
being released published blog post
called PHP a fractal of bad design which
is basically an outdated and irrelevant
blog post of reasons why the author
doesn't like PHP even though half the
things they came out with when they
wrote the posts were wrong and the rest
of them are completely irrelevant and
out of date now
it's over 10 years old and it still gets
a reference to disabled we'll still talk
about this article and link to it and it
drives us all nuts because it's rubbish
most of it is wrong and the rest of it
got fixed ages ago around the same time
we also had um PHP the right way was
created which is uh basically a Web book
for how to build PHP applications
properly I think it was in response to a
fractal or bad design and it goes
through step by step all the different
things you needed to pay attention to
when you're building a PHP out so it's a
great resource
um but so they all happened in uh 2012
um in part of the php5 versions then
after P35 we went on to seven because
six is gone
um and there's not too much to say here
except for we had a bunch of different
releases one after another each of the
years
um each version makes the language
significantly better adds new features
adds cool stuff
um we're not going into the details in
the talk the point is that we're on a
nice solid Cadence here
so where where did it all go wrong what
went wrong with PHP and why do people
have a problem with PHP and you've
probably already figured it out but it's
the php3 and 4 era
which is you know roughly those years so
php3 and four the problem was that it
was a really powerful language and it
did a whole bunch of stuff but there
were no checks in it there was no
structure in it and so it was really
really easy to make big mistakes it
basically gave you all parano safety and
in order to get any structure in your
applications to do any sort of
oh decent application structure and I'm
repeating research but the point is
um in order to do any of that you need
it to build it yourself and manage it
yourself through the functions that the
the language provided because they
didn't have namespaces or decent classes
or anything like that
and so you're limited by what you
implemented in your application
which meant that if you'd made some bad
decisions early on you're stuck with
them which makes it really hard to
maintain a solid and secure application
now the other big problem with PHP at
this time was the double-edged sword of
shared hosting
because back then shared hosting was
cheap and nasty you ever got you got it
for free you've got to pay five dollars
a year five dollars a month if you found
a really expensive shared host and they
all had PHP because it was free and easy
and so anyone who won an application
would set up a would get shared hosting
for paying basically no money and then
use PHP and figure out how to write it
from there and then of course these
people that don't know what they're
doing are setting up their Hosting
account and then writing their own PHP
of course they're going to write
security vulnerabilities because they
don't know what they're doing
shared hosting also installed
applications for you I mean like plask
and cpanel had was it Fantastico maybe I
don't know if anyone remembers those
wonderful glorious shared hosting days
um but yeah and so they shared hosting
would install applications for you so on
technical users could literally just go
into the web interface click a few
buttons have a version of Wordpress
installed or Moodle or Drupal Drupal or
any of the other things but none of them
would get updated or managed and the
settings would be rubbish anyway and the
non-technical people don't know what
they're doing so they're not going to
fix anything so you've got a whole pile
of PHP applications configured and set
up that people don't know how to use
don't know how to manage or secure and
aren't getting updated and that's all
brought about from shared hosting and
granted chat housing also is probably
the reason why it's PHP is so popular
because it was so easy to use and get to
but you know it it's a double-edged
sword
also it's pretty common to have display
errors on by default back in those days
and display errors of course leak
information application and if you're
trying to hack things break into stuff
ceiling steel data you can do it through
display errors as well so that was
happening in that era as well and it was
no decent package manager no way to pull
income and packages reuse packages no
way to update things when there are
security updates so you're basically
stuck with old versions
um as you can see these are the the main
applications you think of when you're
thinking of this error
um cool
so as I mentioned before pair PHP extend
what's it called PHP extension and
application repository so the php's
early package manager but it was kind of
exclusive they only supported one
package that that did a certain job so
if you wanted to do testing and you
wanted to use a pair package you had to
use PHP unit if you wanted to do code
styling you had to use their code
snipper if you wanted to do this thing
you had to use that I want to do that
you have to do that you couldn't use
anything else it was also installed on a
system level
so to do any sort of updates or installs
you had to be the admin of the box or
have elevated privileges to do it and
everything was installed on system level
so if you've got three applications they
all had to use the same version because
they're all accessing the comment common
pair repository on the server so if this
site over here requires a really old
version you can't update it if your site
wants a new one because this site's
going to break
and if you tie that back to Shared
hosting one of the big problems with
shared hosting is the hosts don't want
to update anything they don't want to do
any updates at all because if you've got
to say 150 clients on a server and half
of them requiring old version of PHP and
you update it to a new version they're
going to break and keep in mind these
customers pay you five dollars a year at
most which means that as soon as their
site goes down they will literally call
you up and scream in your ear they're
losing thousands of dollars a minute
because their site is down
trust me I worked in shed hosting I know
and yeah so these customers they pay you
basically money at all are the ones that
yield the loudest about their sites
being down
and so you don't update anything you
don't touch anything because if you
break something then you're going to get
screamed at by the customers that don't
pay you enough to listen to them
um and so in shared hosting what you end
up with is old servers running old
versions and the newer surgeon servers
running new versions and if a customer
wants a new version you migrate them to
a new server and it just gets a complete
massive older versions everywhere and
things get more vulnerable and it just
sets collecting itself right I back to
my point of shared hosting being
horrible
um anyway I'm getting sidetracked so
pair
um oh where was I up to I lost track of
what else I do so pair was difficult to
use if you haven't got that already
um and basically no one wanted to use it
because it was so difficult to use and
so you just copy and pasted code or you
built your own code you didn't actually
use pairs packages for much because it
was just too much of a hassle
luckily for us pear is dead completely
gone and buried and gone yay this is
yeah pair is dead if they're more PHP
developers would be cheering right now
thank you sorry my jokes are terrible
aren't they okay um
another fun one Page by my admin so
patreon my admin suffers from the set
and forget mentality you'd install it to
use it for one thing like you had to
update a field in the database so you'd
install pitch my admin go into the field
up data and then you'd forget your left
Page where Miami installed
and then a hacker comes along later and
discovers it and Brute Forces your
database credentials and then gets into
your database and does whatever it is
they want to do happened all the time we
saw it all the time when I'm cleaning
infected sites and you'd always find
Pitch by admin sitting in a subdirectory
on the website somewhere because they
had to use it for one thing
and you've got the same problem with the
shared hosting and the non-technical
people not knowing what they're doing
and so they're going to upload it and
configure it with their passwords
because they don't have to type them in
which means that you have appear to be
my admin without a password prompt that
gets you straight into the customer's
database sitting on a subdirectory on
their site
and so that's one of the problems with
petroleum and I mean it was a fantastic
tool for what it did it did the job well
and it was really the only option you
had back in those days
but it also caused so many problems
because you would forget about it and
leave it there and you've got abandoned
inside sitting there for ages um with
this running and so then a hacker is
going to find it months or years later
WordPress also came around in the same
time
um the thing about WordPress is it's
full of Legacy code pounds because it
was built during the phv4 era where they
weren't classes and other structures and
so they had to build their own
structures for everything and they also
have really strong backwards
compatibility guidelines which means you
cannot delete any functions you cannot
remove a function in a WordPress or do
any major refactoring and restructuring
of how it works it has to keep working
on the sites that are running it
so you end up with a whole bunch of
Legacy patterns and Legacy requirements
in WordPress because of how it was built
and because of the fact that it's the
things 20 years old
you also have the problem that it's on
what at the moment 43 of websites which
means that it has a humongous user base
and you cannot simply change something
and go oh if it breaks for your site who
cares because that is a huge amount of
sites that are going to break and so you
need to support these sites
um WordPress because they weren't in
decent package managers and anything
like that everything is self-contained
so any of the the components that it
uses have vulnerabilities you have to
update all of Wordpress all of Wordpress
core
um you have the same problem with
abandoned sites so people setting up a
WordPress site and forgetting it's been
there and then it's gonna you know it's
just gonna sit there for months and
years being unused and outdated and then
someone's going to come along Discover
it and hack it we saw that all the time
in fact when cleaning word friends sites
you'd often find a hacker had been in
there for a couple of years
um or even multiple layers of hacks so
you'll be going through and you'll find
some really old vulnerable malicious
code that's sitting in there doing
something quietly and no one's noticed
it because they haven't broken the site
and then recently someone else has
hacked in and broken the site and that's
why they've got you to clean it because
they've realized they've been hacked but
years ago they were hacked in doing
other malicious things
very common on WordPress you've got
non-technical site owners so you know
the guy down the road that runs the shop
doesn't know technology they've got like
their cousin's kid or their neighbor's
kid to set up the WordPress site for
them pay them 20 bucks kids installed
WordPress hasn't really put any care
into it he's just getting 20 bucks you
know it's all it takes five minutes done
no one knows how to run it no one
manages it all the site owner does is
log in occasionally to respond to
comments and the sign gets hacked
because no one does updates and
everyone's afraid of doing updates too
but the real problem with WordPress
isn't the WordPress call it's actually
pretty secure
so at the moment WordPress requires PHP
7.4 which is slightly out of date but
they brought it up recently it was a lot
it was a lot older version recently that
it required but they brought that one up
but it also includes automatic updates
which means that WordPress call will
automatically update when there are
security updates so as long as you're
maintaining your WordPress enough for it
to do updates any security
vulnerabilities in WordPress call will
be updated and your site will protect it
there is an incredibly active security
team working at WordPress WordPress who
look at you know security
vulnerabilities and things and reports
and if there are any issues of plugins
and themes then they'll respond to those
and in general the WordPress core itself
the actual WordPress itself the code is
pretty secure it's very rare for them to
be vulnerabilities in the WordPress core
that are exploited in the wild before
they're fixed they do occasionally get
found and then fixed and then they get
exploited after that after an update
goes out but it's rare for it to be
hacked before the update before people
know about it so you really have a zero
day
um there's also incredibly active
security ecosystem around WordPress like
word fence the company I used to work
for their thing is WordPress security
they make a firewall and a vulnerability
scanner and we clean infected sites so
there's huge security stuff around
WordPress the problem are the vulnerable
plugins and themes because these are
people that don't really know what
they're doing but they want their site
to do something specific and so they'll
set up they'll create their own plugin
for WordPress to do what they want
because they can't find one that does
what they want and because it's so easy
to get started building a plug-in or
just doing PHP in general and these
people don't really know what they're
doing they're just trying to scratch an
edge they're going to produce rubbish
plugins rubbish code which then is what
gets hacked and so the majority of stuff
in WordPress that gets hacked are the
plugins and the themes because they're
the vulnerable bits the bits that are
sitting on top
and I have still have nightmares logging
into some Infected sites and seeing 30
or 40 different WordPress programs
installed yeah
um WordPress same problem with shared
hosting we've been in before the other
big problem that WordPress has though is
there's no multi-factor in the core
um so just resulting in passwords
um and the WordPress Community has a
strange obsession with random unique
usernames
they don't talk about passwords being
random and unique they talk about
usernames being random and unique which
is bizarre because WordPress literally
tells you the username if you ask for it
so yeah I've I've sat through talks
before the speaker has talked about
unique random passwords they're sorry
reading random usernames and not mention
the password and it was just weird
um anyway here's the WordPress stats
just to kind of prove that WordPress is
used a lot I'm sure we already know
these numbers anyway it's pretty
impressive that all the competitors are
down here in WordPress are still massive
up there
and that's kind of one of the problems
with WordPress in the sense that it's
got so much momentum behind it for such
a legacy projects which makes it such a
huge huge Target
ah there we go sorry my clicker doing
weird stuff okay now the other problem
with the PHP training for error was the
roll your own which is where
the variable entry for PHP is really low
it's really really easy to build PHP
apps all you have to do is you know one
line and you can print something on the
screen
add that into the widespread
availability of shared hosting it's free
or really really cheap that sort of
thing it's really easy to do
um what am I trying to say
yeah sorry I completely thought it's
really really easy to build your own PHP
sites and the php3 and 4 era had a lot
of this happening and you combine that
with lots of quick and dirty tutorials
on the internet and you get a world of
pain
because this is example code from a
tutorial that I found online it took me
five minutes to no five seconds to find
it it was the topic in Google for a
simple search term and this is the code
from an actual tutorial that someone is
teaching about PHP and it's been around
for for years
anyone um notice notice the problem
oh one of the problems
yep
so yeah this one's kind of scary
um and this is the comment tutorial and
this person has never actually bothered
to fix it even though it's been online
for years people have left multiple
comments about it this person hasn't
ever fixed it and so this is one of the
problems with the php3 and 4 era is that
everyone's building their own thing and
finding dodgy tutorials from someone who
wrote it quickly doesn't really care
they're not interested in security they
just want people on their site so
they're writing this rubbish and then
you result in hacked sites and
vulnerable sites
so I went to a couple years ago NSE
Security in the Gold Coast and I went
through Troy Hunt's Workshop
and he spent half the time making fun of
me because he found out I was a PHP
developer and so I asked him why you
know why do you pick on PHP so much and
so you opened a web browser and did this
type that in there first hit in Google
and we had this
um so he went to the URL and he added
the apostrophe up in there
um and this kind of proves the problem
with Legacy PHP is there a lot of sites
out there like this that still have
display errors and problems in SQL
injection
because you know they're just abandoned
I don't know if this site still gets
used or not but it's still online and so
PHP does have the negative connotations
from this from the Legacy side of things
um and it's you know just the size and
scale of PHP on the internet makes it
hard to get rid of this but that's kind
of where the negative stuff comes from
but php5 and Beyond things change things
got better
so one of the first one of the things
that happened during the php5 era was
setting up a release Cadence and as
you'll notice we went through the
timeline of releases that the years were
every year and so what they did was they
switched to two years of active support
for each version and then a year of
security sport for the version and you
can see here each year they're releasing
and then you've got the 8.1 8.2 with the
currently it's currently active support
and then you've got eight xero has
security support
and so the point of this is to keep the
language moving and keep it going along
and then all the Frameworks and all the
tools that want to remain relevant in
the space need to keep updated as well
which in turn keeps security updates and
everything else moving along because
things have to keep up with this Cadence
otherwise they're going to fall behind
and I think this is one of the things
that helped WordPress get into
where it is now with with updated
versions and things
so I mentioned the PHP for four so Petri
fig is the PHP framework
interoperability group and it's a group
of leaders from various Frameworks and
Community groups in the PHP community
that came together and they developed a
list of standards and they started off
with the psr0 auto loading standard
which is probably the most significant
of the list although it's been replaced
by four now but it's the most
significant on the list and um
this is what it looks like so a lot of
learning standard defines how different
packages and different projects in PHP
should structure their code so that you
can take anyone else's package and plug
it into your into your program into your
app and the idea is that rather than
having to figure out how every different
package does their thing because
everything was different before this you
had to do require statements and every
all the naming was different and you
have complex and version them problems
and all those all the naming issues but
then the auto Learning Center came out
and did some really cool things so first
of all up here you've got the following
structure you've got a vendor name
namespace and then class name so vendor
name is the vendor it's like the user or
the company in my case it's valorin I
mean you've got namespace it starts off
with the project name so my one of my
packages is valorian slash Point
password slash whatever the class names
are and the way what this means is that
every bit of PHP you try to pull in that
uses the automating standard is version
to the vendor first so you're never
going to get a conflict between vendors
because they all have their own name and
then you've got the package and so on
from there and then using php's auto
loading all you have to do is include
the one file then it will automatically
find all these files for you so using
and reusing other people's code was
really really easy from this point
because you didn't have to deal with all
the messy naming problems you could just
drop the code in and that would work
and following on from the heels of this
we had composer which is php's package
manager and in my opinion it is the best
package manager that's ever been made
the PHP built uses the auto loading
standard to make it really really easy
to pull in PHP packages from packages
which is the Repository and unlike
things like npm because it uses the
vendor name first you're never going to
get vendor
um you're getting it name conflict
you're also it's really hard to get typo
squatting unless you're actually type of
scoring the vendor as well because you
need to get the vendor and then the
package names the type of squatting is a
lot harder in this it also does it per
project dependencies rather than on the
server which is something that pair was
doing so each project can have its own
versions and pull in everything else
rather than having to rely on the server
which solves that problem
another easy version looking that was by
default from the start something that
NBN took forever to add in on my ad and
so that made it really easy to ensure
that the versions of the package you're
using on your local development are on
the deployments ETC it pulls it all from
GitHub and other repositories as well so
the code you're getting is the code in
the public repository not some other
package that's been put to the
repository that gives you that awareness
as well in there which is nice
and there were no external dependencies
you didn't need to install anything on
the system to use it it's just a PHP
file
which made it really really easy to use
and and
Implement in your applications because
you didn't need to ask the administrator
to add anything it was just there and
ready to go
um basically composer allowed computer
made it really really easy to reuse
common components so no longer were you
re-implementing everything from scratch
or manually copy pasting code you would
just use a composer to install it and
then update it using a simple command
which which solved a lot of the problems
and it really brought about modern PHP
because it gave all of the the magic
package management stuff that you needed
to build proper applications and keep
them updated
there are also a bunch of third-party
tools you can use for checking composer
packages to make sure they're updated
there are no known vulnerabilities and
they've recently added in composer audit
as well which does the same thing as
part of composer so it makes it really
easy to check for known vulnerabilities
and keep things updated and it pulls
from like github's vulnerability
database Etc
and then following on from composer we
had the Frameworks coming in which we're
using compose that are pulling the
packages and the benefit of this
um is that your common packages like I
mentioned guzzle before and Doctrine and
so the Frameworks could use those rather
than having to build their own wrapper
around curl so Google is the wraparound
curl that makes it really easy to do
HTTP requests and things and rather than
having to replement your own you could
just use guzzle and which is a rock
solid package and everyone can use it
there's a logging package a monologue
which everything uses
and the idea was the Frameworks made it
really easy to reuse code and use common
trusted well-used well-known code rather
than having to rebuilt their own all the
time
so the PHP Frameworks in the 5678 era
not takes five percent you know pH of
the Frameworks they follow security best
practices mostly and so when you deploy
when you start building an application
using a petri framework one of the
modern Frameworks you're getting best
practices out of the box you're not
needing to learn Security on your own or
figure out how to solve the problems it
comes for you they give you rock solid
scaffolding for things like
authentication and session and cookies
and database connections and all the
different things you need in your
application it comes in the framework so
again you don't have to implement that
stuff you just do your application logic
you don't have to set up all the rest of
the nonsense
they're using a poser as I mentioned
before Common dependencies they have
really active communities around them
like laravel which is the most popular
PHP framework has a huge Community
around it teaching best practices and
not just Integrity but encoding in
general and because it because of the
built-in security features within the
Frameworks and the communities around
telling you how to use them and the best
way to build your applications it makes
it really easy to build a solid secure
applications using these Frameworks
because it gives you all those tools and
all the knowledge you need to use them
rather than having to figure it out for
yourself and figure out how to roll your
own security which never works well
as a good example so in laravel
in order to add csrf protection so um
cross-site request forgery protection
it's actually enabled by default anytime
you deploy a laravel application unless
you change the settings in order to
submit a form to it you need to to add
in a csrf token this little bit up here
wait I've got to say for this that
little thing up there those five
characters are all you need to get csrf
protection in laravel that's it it does
everything else for you it checks the
requests coming in and blocks anything
that's missing that token
so CSF isn't a problem in laravel
because it's just there by default you
have to actively disable it in order to
introduce a csrf vulnerability
oops okay SQL injection is another one
that the the Frameworks get rid of
because you've got a fluent
um encode way of doing SQL SQL queries
you're not going to have parameter
parameterization issues and injection
problems if you're writing a code like
this because here's your parameter here
and the code automatically knows it has
to escape that you actually have to go
out of your way to add in raw database
Clauses in order to get any form of
injection vector and again they're
really easy to add parameters into
because it's all part of the syntax and
Cake PHP has got a similar thing over
there
so the Frameworks make it really easy to
avoid issues like this and I rarely say
SQL injection vulnerabilities in these
in frame one PHP Frameworks because they
give you this and it just makes it so
easy to write the secure code
Crystal scripting is another one you've
got blade templating and Twig templating
a bunch of templating engines that out
of the box do escaping for you so these
double curlies they escape things so by
default when you're outputting stuff
onto the screen it's automatically
escaped crossover scripting isn't really
a problem you've also got Advanced um
things like loops and if statements and
continues and etc for doing your
scripting you don't have to embed manual
PHP into the template you use the
templating engine which means you're
less likely to get manual PHP which has
vulnerabilities in it
so across that scripting is not really a
thing either that you see and unless
it's in special cases
content security policy if you're using
what is it done with coding either
coding either by default comes with a
Content security policy class that's its
default settings it is turned off by
default but all you have to do is toggle
a Boolean variable and then you get
content security policy being delivered
in your application straight away so
piece of cake add a Content security
policy and codeigniter
if you're running Cake PHP you've got a
whole bunch of functions here out of the
box to enable various security headers
in your application against a single
line to turn on like referral policy or
um the defunct xss Protection One so
really really simple out of the box
framework gives it to you automatically
um and it's worth pointing out that the
other languages like Frank laravel
adding in these sorts of headers and
adding content security policies is
really simple it's just oh for in
laravel for a Content security policy I
have uh GitHub just that has two files
in it you just copy put them into your
level application and it gives you a
Content security policy it's that simple
to add them in there's not the
complexity needed to add these
structures into applications they're
just there
authenticating authentications um
scaffolding is important too and you get
those hilarable gives you Breeze and jet
stream which are two fully featured
authentication systems a couple of
lining um you know command lines and it
installs it all for you then you have an
application that indicates a jet stream
there's login and registration and
two-factor authentication and password
reset
um and user profile management
um you can see sessions as well and kick
other users that even so it does all
these different things and that's just
like three lines in your console to
install and get all the dependencies in
there codeigniter has Shield which I
haven't used but I think it does a
similar sort of thing gives you the full
authentication scaffolding there are
also a bunch of third-party
um packages in composer and packages
that give you pass keys and u2s totps
and there's also packages that do secure
billing as well interact with stripe and
paddle and a bunch of those other
billing systems and all of that is
really easy out of the box type stuff
you just get a default install the
default application then run a few more
commands to pull in extra packages it'll
configure it all itself for you and then
you have an application where you can
start doing your application logic and
you have all the authentication already
set up for you don't have to worry about
any of it which is really really cool
PHP by default it's not just the premise
of HP by default has this function here
filter input which you can use for
validating inputs and also
sanitizing inputs as well so any user
input you've got coming in you can pass
it through here make sure it's in the
right format and get rid of any of the
stuff you don't want to be in there so
it makes filtering and validating inputs
are really really simple
in laravel it has over 90 different
validators that you can use for
validating your input and the validator
itself is really really easy to use
these are a couple of my favorites but
you can see there's heaps of different
options in here
um and if you look at the password one
you can just configure the password
rules like that so if you need minimum
of eight lead eight eight characters
needed to be mixed case that you can do
that and Out of the Box laravel gives
you uncompromise which calls the point
password API so you can check your
passwords haven't been compromised and
prevent people from using them in
registration password change that sort
of thing so really really simple that's
just that class and we have to do is
call those to configure it and you can
set up as a global policy in the
application so rather than having to do
it on every single endpoint you just set
it once then they can all inherit the
password rules really simple
so this is my favorite laravel security
feature I absolutely love this one this
is assigned routes so the idea of
assigned route is that when you need to
give someone a URL that cannot be
guessed or maybe cannot be changed so
for an unsubscribe link for example when
you want their email address but you
don't want anyone to be able to
unsubscribe anyone else you can use the
signed link and then you pass in their
email address or their ID as it is on
the picture there and then it'll
generate a secure link from that which
you'll have a signature on it
then when they click on the link it has
to validate the signature against the
parameters in the URL so to generate the
link all you do is that that one line
there you can make it temporary so it's
an expiry date or you can just do signed
route and then it's no expiry at all
then all you need down here is this has
valid signature or you can use the
middle F and that validates the sale
Insurance checks for the query
parameters and if it doesn't pass then
it automatically rejects the request
in this case we're going to abort 401.
so that's all you need is those two
lines one up here one up here one down
here in order to actually do signed URLs
which is really it makes it really easy
and I love them they're fantastic little
feature
um and the PHD Frameworks are full of
this sort of conveniency things they've
got all sorts of little security
features like that that make it really
easy to do stuff that was previously
complicated but now it's easy it's
either you've just got two lines there
to do that and that's doing things like
hmac
um hashing and such
sorry
okay so the record to wrap up
um as I said at the start I spent last
year ordering laravel sites and ordering
security of them and so these are the
top five things that I saw when doing my
audits in terms of security of modern
PHP applications specifically Lara for
once and the top thing that I found
that's a problem is the non-critical
security misconfiguration so we're
talking missing security headers content
security policy SRI Etc
and these are the things that are
non-critical so if they're missing the
site isn't vulnerable but they're there
in case something else happens so you
want sris and some resource Integrity in
case a third party gets compromised
because then it'll stop third-party
compromise from attack from
um
from getting to your users because
they'll sort their scripts from running
you want to kind of ask content security
policy to start cross-site scripting
from happening on your site if someone
if if there is another vulnerability in
there but on their own it's not a
problem if they're not there
um so that's that's the top thing that's
missing is just the lack of awareness on
what sort of security headers and things
should be set there but as I said it's
not a critical problem it's not I can't
hack them if I find they're missing a
CSP
the second thing is committed
credentials
um you know it's the most common one I
find are actually slack URLs because
they've got the key in the URL and so
they're always scattered across the code
bases rather than pulled out into a
config file so find stack your other law
and occasionally AWS credentials and fun
things like that community in the git
history and so it's pretty easy to find
and this is probably pretty common
across all the applications we work on
not just PHP
um and again critic media credentials
you're not going to be able to hack a
site from that alone because you need to
get to the repository you need to get to
their code to find the credentials to do
anything with it so it's not a critical
problem unless someone else already gets
in and gets access to the code
third thing outdated packages we
probably saw this one coming it's a
problem for everyone curiously enough
it's usually node npm packages that are
outdated on laravel and PHP sites
composer less so
um I think updating npn is harder to
remember and just more painful than
updating composer who here hasn't done a
fourth upload undelete of the node dumb
modules repository before
yeah I thought so
we've all done it many times yeah I
realized it's outside now the right if
you think I'm going to say it yeah but
anyway so yeah so athletic packages so
these three are probably pretty common
across all applications I'd be very
surprised if someone who does pen
testing and code audits comes up and
says no why don't you see that sort of
problem in my applications now the next
one this one is actually a I can hack
your site with it um problem but this is
simple mistakes on single routes
so I'm not talking about where the the
developers don't understand security or
they just lack an awareness of what
authorization is this is where the
developer has simply forgotten the line
they've done a simple bug simple mistake
and so say you've got a controller
that's got five actions in it and one of
those is missing your authorization call
that checks up the user as an admin it
happens occasionally and it's easy to
forget when you're writing down your
code and you forget that one line
I find that all the time and often leads
to idors
um and things like that and you often
also get with the signed routes that I
mentioned before
they'll sometimes forget to actually
validate the signature so you'll
generate a sun route but if they're not
validating the signature then you just
drop the signature and you can change
whatever you want and you get in
um so it's just these really simple bugs
are the most problem things that I find
and you get that in everything that's
not not anything laravel is PhD specific
um and then after that that I find most
common are actually cross-out scripting
vulnerabilities but it's usually in
escalated or elevated accounts so admins
or say moderators the most recent one I
found was
um a video upload so not video upload so
video embed so the moderator was able to
embed a video from a weekly thing in in
on the page and then they just accepted
all HTML in order to do the video in bed
so you can inject your own JavaScript in
there they did accept the risk because
the moderators who were doing who had
access knew what they were doing and it
was just part of what they had to do and
they had to support different video
providers so that was an acceptable risk
but that's definitely what I find
because I'm scripting is it's in an
elevated account it doesn't not usually
in a lower level account
and that's all I really find to be
honest it's occasionally I find some
other things but in general it comes
under you know the only the the ways to
hack them generally comes on number four
it's through the simple mistakes so
they've just forgotten something simple
here and there
um and that's my that's modern PHP
there's really not when you're using a
proper PHP language and you're doing
following the best practices and working
in the communities and using the tools
that are provided you don't generally
find a lot of security vulnerabilities
because it is secured it's safe it does
have all these things in there for you
to make it easy
so PHP isn't all that bad hopefully you
come away knowing that so thank you very
much for coming uh are there any
questions
yep
um
developer who works as I helped a lot of
students
um
grandpa language
um I think this has at least changed my
view on on PHP as I didn't know that was
that there was this matter but when I
talked to to everyone else why would we
learn PHP instead of JavaScript when
this index is very similar to that job
which we were always brought into an
Enterprise and where almost every job
hosting requires react rectangular or
two I have never ever in my life seen a
uh any PHP framework and a job closing
if you're going to run into uh in react
and stuff like that yeah okay so the
question was why pick PHP over other
languages like JavaScript and such um
so oh I guess my defense for that would
be that I mean when you're writing PHP
you still need to know JavaScript so you
still need the front-end language but
PHP was designed to run on the server
JavaScript wasn't and so when you're
building a language that an application
that requires server-side components and
server-side things in my view is you
should use a server-side language a
language is designed to run in the
server and designed to do with things
and is really good at it rather than
using a language that's kind of been
hacked to run on the server and then
like server-side rendering really just
use a server side language and build a
page
um so I mean
I guess you know as you call it the
grandpa language and I guess yeah it is
in its fashion as exciting as modern
things but it gets the job done and gets
the job really well job done really well
and pretty much like laravel make it
really easy to build really cool sites
there are some really nice things like
inertia and Live Wire coming out for
laravel that do to take away the
JavaScript for you so you don't really
do need to do much of them because they
do all that magic for you
and so then you can focus on writing
your code in your application and doing
the server-side things then they do the
front-end interface for you
um
so yeah I would in
yeah I mean I I I prefer pastry I find
it's really easy to use and I think
um I'm trying to think of a better way
to defend it but I guess you've got to
use the language it works for you and I
would say don't dismiss it if um if you
haven't tried it especially you can go
trusting like something like laravel and
see what you think of it
yep
we started talking about
um
PHP being being server-side yep but PHP
is still a language that lends itself
towards server rendered pages right
which is I guess that's really
where
um developer taste comes in and and I
would say personally I am more of the um
what do you say more more of the opinion
that
um
I prefer the the client server
architecture where I build a an API and
a single page application for example
yep and
then my JavaScript can be as dumb as
possible and my server will do
everything
I'm sure you can do that in PHP but
that's not really what people do is it
um so the just for painting for the
recording so the comment was saying that
um the person the guy prefers writing um
client server applications and so
um yeah keep you know like an API for
the server and then the the client and
um spas and all those things
um well the thing of it PHP and is you
it is really easy to build an API and
build that side of things and so if you
want to go down the path of having an
spa and then a backend API it's really
easy to do that and laravel has a whole
bunch of tools to do that for you so
building an API for an Spa in laravel is
a piece of cake you don't have to use
PHP as a
at the back as a rendering tool for
rendering the pages you can easily use
it for apis and it works really well for
that
um and it's quite performance for that
performance for that as well because you
can optimize your code based on the API
architecture so if you're going to go
down that route of having your front end
app and your backend out use your
backend read the back end language that
is designed for backend PHP is designed
for backend whether it be rendering HTML
Pages or just doing an API on doing API
responses it still works really well for
that
so yeah I I think it works well for that
and there are like as I said laravel
does provide all the tools you need to
do an API in it
um so yeah
yep
um so the final question is it common
that people do that and yes I think it
is there is a lot of one of the what's
it called um level inertia I mentioned
before
um I said no it's just inertia's not
level inertia it's
it's a way of using building that in
that um laravel apps in in that way
where you build a front-end null in View
and then it handles all of the complex
review stuff for you
um and then it uses laravel as an API as
the back end to power it
um and so it is quite common people to
use um laravel as a backhand and use PHP
as a backend for svas and they're
reverse plan packages that you can
install that really that give you easy
jwts and other session authentication
tokens things to to use it as a back-end
for an API yeah so I think it is quite
common
um yep
also all the Frameworks
and new things for you but you can still
use all those old boot camps in modern
version PHP you can only use that much
right again still write that SQL
injection examples
yep yeah that's the current was that
your PHP my defense is that PHP is all
about the Frameworks and that's what
gives it security
um yes but you can do that in any
language
um I mean because any language if you're
looking at the raw language without any
Frameworks at all it gives you all the
tools you need to shoot yourself in the
foot
um the thing about modern PHP ignoring
all the Frameworks is it gives you the
class of the namespaces and a whole
bunch of functions and features built
into the core that you can use to to
build a secure application you need to
know what you're doing though
um but with the Frameworks come in to
make it easy for people who don't know
what they're doing to get started and
still get the security features but if
you know what you're doing and this is
the same with any application any
framework don't know any any language at
all if you know what you're doing you
can use the raw framework and write a
secure application
um just the modern PHP is the PHP you
know 7A specifically give you a whole
bunch of the tools to make it really
easy
and you've got like that filter or the
filter input function which is part of
the core so you've got input validation
built into the course that's already a
tool you can use straight away you don't
need a framework for that and I know the
PHP common library has huge amount of
functions and features in there also
like JavaScript has a very limited set
in its core and you need to pull in 50
gazillion packages via MBM in order to
do anything in JavaScript but PHP has so
many different things built into the
core so I mean you could argue that
there's more in PHP core to build an
application than there is in other
languages
based on my limited understanding of
yep
Google
like I think it was uh how to how to
read from a file or something like that
yeah in PHP you get like you get all
kinds of insecure code for like
something like Dominion Facebook which
is I think which is pretty common to
indeed is yeah immediately but they have
the answer yeah
how is it if the PHP Community is so
strong and built
are still online that's like the first
thing that everyone sees
how is that being possible if the
communities like if you Google 11 Java
you don't get a immediately you find a
SQL injection uh or ability by Google
how to do spring boots or something like
that you know
um yes the question is how are they
still insecure tutor also easy to find
on search engines
um
I'm guessing the blame there falls on
the search engines um rather than the
community itself because there are I can
I can point to again heaps of different
resources for for PHP that teach how to
do a proper PHP and proper code
um so I I as for why Google still
returns those really old tutorials first
I don't know that's just how they work
um
uh yeah I don't really have a good
answer to that one I mean it's because
you can't take down someone else's site
I mean people have like why not put up
there with the um
the SQL injection I think that's an
example that tryhardt uses in his
workshop and he's tried multiple times
to leave comments on that guy's blog
about how it's insecure the person just
deletes the comments so the person
running that site knows full well that
it's vulnerable and they don't care
they're just keeping it up there because
it's getting traffic to their site they
must have ads or something
so I'd suggest that the the insecure
tutorials are up there either done
through a set and forget mentality
someone's forgotten it's a thing and
they're not checking it or they like
they're getting ad on revenue or
something or I don't know that I don't
know but in terms of I think it's the
the search engine's fault that people
are that they're so easy to find when
they're so outdated
and it's probably why PHP practical
about design keeps getting talked about
as well because it's really easy to find
even though it's old and outdated but
you know the person that wrote it keeps
it up there and the session just keep
finding it so
yeah and if there's something from
Google here we could ask them
don't know if that really answers the
question but hopefully it does
yep yep
uh uh again from the point of view of
somebody who is said just saying
important money yes yep uh a lot of uh
you know from a job if you want to get
into that that right it's react kind of
Time interview it does all the
applications if you want to do some Java
you know you need strings that needs to
download essentially if you want to run
in public sector you learn Java I
haven't seen a PHP session like that's
like I I haven't heard about Marvel
before I was like huh that's a framework
for PHP
yeah
yeah you are more into that space do you
see a lot of job posting
I guess I only look at no one right so
yeah I haven't seen it
it's not like is
there is this I don't maybe because I'm
not in those four right
um yeah there are heaps of big sites
that use laravel and other Frameworks um
excuse me in PHP so yeah there are
definitely job jobs going up for page
pay and companies that are hiring page
pay um governments tend to go for the
more
corporate type language just because
governments do government stuff and
that's just what governments do
um and also large companies those the
older ones generally get
um again kind of gravitate towards the
more corporate languages they're just
kind of what seems to happen so you put
your own PHP more in smaller smaller
shops and you're like agencies and such
using PHP
um and that sort of thing
but yeah there are definitely PHP jobs
and things
um around
um if you know where to look I guess
it's just a case of looking but I think
a lot of the feature Community probably
looks for jobs in different locations as
well and so you know you might not be
seeing them in those spaces because the
companies are advertising in different
places
yeah you definitely get the whole we've
got Legacy code thing but you've also
get yeah when you're looking for laravel
developer Symphony developers
um codeigniter that sort of thing so if
there's definitely an active community
and there's definitely jobs and things
around for it so it's not as if it's uh
everyone working in are the only ones
who are ever going to do it again sort
of thing there's definitely definitely
growing there's definitely that in there
um but you hear more about some of the
other languages and some of the other
things just because
I don't know it's a yeah I don't really
know I mean I it could just be there's
not much PHP up in this part of the
world as well depending on what sort of
jobs you're looking for
um so yeah
cool we might call that a
or that a session um
thank you very much